[Music]
the podcast primary Democrats logging
more than 1200 podcast appearances ahead
of 20/20 but one campaign strategy work
well here to weigh in is Michael Knowles
host of the Michael Knowles show Michael
are we at the podcast primary point at
this point we absolutely are totally
unselfishly as host of the Michael Nolt
show podcast and the sitting president
to come on podcasts because as you see
from 2016 to the present podcast
audiences are way up in 2016 about 36%
of Americans had ever listened to a
podcast today that number is over 50%
and the audience's skew much younger
which is very important because unlike
in 2016 in 2020 Millennials will
approach if not surpass the baby boomers
as the largest eligible voter group in
America this obviously is particularly
important for Democrats who rely on
young voters to go out there to mobilize
their voter effort but a president Trump
can't afford to ignore podcasts either
it's also a much more intimate format
that's why the ad rates are so much more
expensive than they are on say radio to
ignore podcasts in the 2020 election
would be like ignoring television in
1950s and that did not turn out very
well for at least Evensen yeah Mike
let's take a look at some of the 20/20
Democrats who have logged the most
appearances number one you have marianne
williamson 154 appearances total airtime
over four days to andrew yang ninety
eight appearances total airtime two days
13 hours number three mr. Joe Biden 371
appearances one day 23 hours and pee
Buddha judge 72 appearances one day 11
hours Tim Ryan yeah one day nine hours
54 podcast appearances so who do you
think needs this most is my question to
you because I think Joe Biden actually
could benefit from this a lot he needs
to get some of his personality and some
of his energy out there particularly
with young voters who might be drawn to
Bernie Sanders to the Elizabeth Warren's
of the world to the aoc style wing of
the Democratic Party
of course Joe Biden has been in politics
since about the mid 19th century so I
think if he wants to prove to voters
that he's got some modern appeal and
relevance he has
to do it but I think what this shows you
is that podcasts as a medium cuts across
all sorts of candidates you have these
fringe candidates like Marianne
Williamson who are benefiting the only
way that they're getting their message
out there and getting their name out
there is by going on these alternative
media and you have people like Joe Biden
who is establishment as it gets
they are Joe Biden is also not ignoring
podcasts and I think President Trump
should should focus on it as well you
know he is the king of social media when
it comes to politics and the new
frontier is podcast bottom bottom line
which you lay out about Millennials list
these podcasts and in full disclosure I
ran a half-marathon with my 18 year old
daughter I was listening to Led Zeppelin
to motivate me she was listening to a
podcast I couldn't believe it
bottom line is it your view then that
the key to the Millennial vote is
reaching those podcasts absolutely
technology is changing rapidly so are
the media and if Twitter was the key to
2016 if YouTube was the key to 2008 and
2012 podcasting is the key to 2020
thanks Michael for being here and I hope
you book some of these big guns on your
podcast I will be tuning in for that
podcast